everybody what's going on played here
I'm here with Damian Lillard point guard
for the Portland Trailblazers as well as
the face of NBA Live 15 yes that's
awesome that's amazing I just have a
quick question before we start I noticed
the EA Sports logos in a certain plate
that something happened here during the
photo shoot they had to just let's just
stick the logo right there I thought it
went pretty well yeah awesome perfect
alright so the game came out yesterday
so we're gonna play a little NBA Live 15
you ready not only ready I am a Pistons
fan I'm guessing you're gonna play the
Trailblazers that's exactly perfect and
alright let's do it
get the old a button there yeah man it's
okay heck yeah
you won't are you guys where we're at
home but I like blue I'm a fan of blue
I'm gonna go blue I like it I like it
alright just tip it off it's not worried
about coaching in that stuff so we got
some fan questions for you you ready
this is gonna be you're gonna have to
multitask or you have to play and deal
with fan questions you ready Ruby what's
the first fan question okay at the
Pelican man wants to know what
basketball nickname would you give Conan
oh that's a good question besides eating
I think it's what he's known as on the
court currently what would name when I
give big ginger ivory-tower maybe get
off the court mister get off the court
oh man he looks so cool in this game I
mean you look cool in real life also
I guess there's everything yeah that's
awesome
really Brennan perfect perfect no way do
you know how to remember I play if the
buttons aren't saying yeah yeah man I'm
gonna get soaked yeah I said this before
but I am really bad at sports game oh
this is gonna be it this could be a
beating it's gonna be an absolute
beating I'm also get out of here
I'm also terrible at sports in real life
so I don't know if then I can't even
make a layup so what did you have to do
- they did - they did some kind of
scanning on your face right
I did like motion capture and they did
like make sick pictures of my face and
all the way around that sauce like you
have hundred canvases
that's insane I love that it's like the
ultimate selfie kind of then you also
preserve you from every angle
yes selfie 15 ankle I love it all right
another question
oh geez all right just by the people are
so nice noticing easy City to play for
hey see it's tough isn't it it's tough
but you're still I haven't scored a
point by the way so keep that only I had
two possessions that's June's it studio
arrow me oh I think is like the people
there make it so easy to play for them
you know we got the greatest fans or the
lead not just love who is anywhere else
I love our fans that's awesome now you
who else on the team do you play games
video games on the road see it is a
thing I'm we I'm terrible at video games
so I don't play against nobody
yeah just play by myself Oh
guess if you're good in real life you
don't have to uh if you're actually in a
video game
DM up oh if you actually play
professional I know but if you haven't
play pro sports in real life you don't
need to pretend that you're a basketball
player because you are less male there
we go but you have to go to play games
people that's a terrible investment
water like that's should kill me ending
video that's [ __ ] all right here we go
all right roofie hit us what do you got
a problem how far do you think the
Trailblazers can get this year I think
we can accomplish whatever we want to
accomplish on tape we've got to get
better in some areas and I think we will
get better in those areas so I think we
just got to tighten up the things that
we didn't do well last year Hulme in a
team yeah it's awesome and work hard
right good things will happen there's
one of the teams that you you like
playing against the most is there give a
favorite team you're just like on me I
like playing on the stage why is that
because I get the plague is my hometown
yeah
because of the challenge yeah for sure
I love playing it's not my family every
time I play them I didn't come home and
play a president very part of people
that I grew up around it's gotta be
super fun I have a kind of a weird
question you ready for a weird question
because I don't know a lot of words
who's the sweetest-smelling player in
the NBA who would you say smells the
best question yeah have you ever been
asked that question I feel like made me
know that's weird you by the way you
could say I prefer not to answer it fast
a little bit yeah you definitely look
the best man you look awesome
all right throw it up throw it up oh
come on I know I'm trying
the sad part is I'm really trying
actually not even kidding I really am
trying nothing's nothing is psyched me
out for an interview more than
practicing this game and having you in
the game just destroyed like before you
came in here I was kind of afraid to
even meet you because I was like this
guy's been scouring me all day
it's like horrifying at the end there's
a really cool thing NBA Live 15 has
great postgame wrap-up where they show
highlights and they kind of comment on
your game and it's like all you just
like crazy like insane probably wouldn't
dumb game yeah did you respond about
trying to get a new dunk or that's the
easiest one to get to no traffic and
it's the easiest wants me to do for ya I
just stick today thank you simple I like
it that's sure I mean at the end of the
story you get up there sure yeah
yeah y'all gotta jump that's it they
just do a little hop and then they can
spend a lot of time here oh don't throw
it up his whole team is laughing at me
there's like nine people over here
they're all just like shaking their
heads and laughing it's disgusting man I
think you're allowed to ball hog in your
own game yeah awesome how accurate are
the tattoos I mean everything is like
per day really yeah that's crazy
did you have any oh God
this is this is I just want to make
double digits is that too much dad did
you did you have any thoughts about
maybe asking them to put in a couple
tattoos II don't have just to see how
they would look
oh that was green and a great reliance
on junk I do no no that's a poster
that's offensive trailblazers posters
here we don't get a lot of posters it
was this gave us Oh all right any other
questions really Friday super successful
you did it on the show a little it's
awesome
well bar Fridays was gonna be there for
them every week that makes take this and
still in the beginning stages I love it
definitely going to happen who are some
of your getting around today who are
some your hip-hop influences um I really
like NAS yeah I like common I like Jake
Oh
like now if you had to if you had to
name any non-healing the computer Garvey
right now oh there we go
ah I gotta do something here we go
take the big man yeah don't get in there
finally oh man
guys I got eight points I got eight
points everybody still whole team
laughing of eight all the EAP for like
dude what is your problem
this is we've had testers who are see me
I just go for me be like me oh there we
go
never leave me open like that never all
right because I'll probably bottle it
and just give it to you and that would
be embarrassing for my team
this is awful this is atrocious
when is it coming out yeah in it when
the car goes in and out is a surprise
and I loved in the Lord I had a lot of I
played a huge part in the way
so yeah excited about that did you just
did you uh did you get to pick your
shoes on the cover of NBA Live 15 did I
get did you pick the shoes that you're
wearing on there those shoes was kind of
like my ideas like yeah they're design
on them and everything
no let me ask you a question can you I
can you bring back remember they had the
shoes for kids with the lights in the
bottom those I think I liked you yeah
can you bring those back or maybe put
like a pocket or something you know like
anti-cruise I feel like my shoe line
probably wouldn't sell it's like it's
like remember that Simpsons episode
where Homer gets to design a car and
it's terrible that would be a pointer to
tell ya mean she's all right Ricky you
got one more yeah Thomas Mickey wets
wants to know what was going through
your head when you second all just
erupted it was so much going on in that
series
yeah it was a competitive series then we
had so much animosity built up towards
each other that when I made it I was
just I was so happy that it was just
like I was with only not definite do you
uh are there situations where you
obviously are very competitive on the
court but then as soon as that as soon
as the game is done are you guys friends
or does it still carry over are you
meant to manage to leave that on the
court or not so mommy I'll leave it on
the court but it's I think it's certain
players they just have something hits
yelling beep and all your guys on the
court right now if I see any of these
guys in the game off the court there
should be a mode like in wrestling where
like you meet him on the parking lot and
then like you do like a ladder battle
I'm just saying
WWE very very very popular sports man
murdering me shocker
perfect get in there if you uh if you
weren't you're a basketball player what
would you do what would you want to do
like it's a job besides taking me to
school in this game it's like oh yeah
there we go I can't believe that you
said that you weren't good at video
games this is ridiculous
it's gonna be on my tombstone here we go
what it by the way what is the
Trailblazers logo what is that it looks
like a it looks like on that it looks
like when they do the local weather it's
like the storm I mean it's better than a
horse which is what the Pistons have
right it's got a horse dancing around oh
there we go
by the way I don't play this game I
didn't even do that that was the totally
computer my horse on the sidelines
all right well fourth quarter I'm not
sure if I'm gonna be able to pull it
back 18 to 31 what time it is I don't
want to know I don't want to know what
time it time did you should come out
with a watch line that could be the
slogan for the watch Chloe awesome
that's pretty dope watch right on over
is where right now ah how many pairs of
shoes do you own to be honest
a couple hundred really yeah have you
ever thought about just like a craft
project with all the shoes he's making
like a little house out of shoes or
something same yeah we've got so many
hues that's awesome
across a lot of tips in the trades pitch
jump open rebound what is the problem
oh man is it
I feel like now you're just playing with
me cats win with them out
oh there we go that's right guys good
ball movement get in there get in there
that's the way it's telling you drive to
the hoop right drive to the weird a
winning rate oh my god nope nope that's
not good
serious a question for you a real
question me as real as I can muster
there we go
I mean statistically one of them have to
go in your pick sixth overall in the
draft couple years back what is it like
on drafting for somebody who I'm
guessing I will never be drafted to
anything ever
are you know what's it like are you
nervous you're obviously there with like
your family never gotten nervous really
what were you nervous about I wanted to
I wanted to give everybody a job ladies
oh really that's awesome just because of
opportunity at my position yeah
and I want to stay on the west coast I
was I was kind of nervous about getting
drafted 218 I was like far away yeah
yeah for sure so you're stuck the way
things are no just get score 2.0 can't
buy a basket man come on I got 40
seconds I could still do it right yeah
thanks
really is that what it is oh my god this
is like just get you oh there we go by
the way not me again the computer I love
this what are you saying you've got
almost double my points I know there we
go here we go
is there a 40 pointer shot there
somewhere in the court where I can be
like am I gonna do
no no no no you didn't even need it
my goodness well do you thank you this
is awesome D me alone everybody follow
them on Twitter name underscore Lillard
and go get this game no one can be worse
than this gaming than me I love it
perfect it looks just like you amazing
awesome thanks guys we now return you to
your normal schedule playing video games